you can subscribe to the spectator
for 12 weeks for only 12 pounds for our
print and online editions
plus get six months of digital access
free to the telegraph
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash telegraph
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
every week a few of our writers read out
their pieces in the magazine
this week we're going to be joined by
douglas murray who talks about how
right-wing candidates can be
life-changing for the bbc and other
public institutions
we also hear from sam leath in defense
of weakness
meanwhile melissa kite defends fly
tipping and at the very end toby young
on why lawrence fox's new political
party
is a good idea first douglas murray
a beautiful noise rang out last week in
the wake of the news that the government
is considering charles moore to become
the new chairman of the bbc
and paul daker to be the head of the
broadcasting watchdog
ofcom the noise was the sound of the
british left
wailing that toys they thought were
theirs alone
might now under a conservative
government
finally go to identifiable conservatives
the former editor of the guardian alan
rusbridger
shrieked that this is what an oligarchy
looks like
this and similar tweets were presumably
sent from the lodgings of the oxford
college that russ bridger was made
principle of five years ago
others who screamed themselves sick
included bbc
employees who briefed that moore's
appointment
would shatter morale people will leave
for there can be no greater way to
refute accusations of institutional
leftism in the bbc
than for the corporation's employees to
threaten to resign on mass
in response to a conservative
appointment
elsewhere have i got news for you
tweeted out
that this would be the end for the bbc
which is as funny a joke as that show
has mustered in the present
century of course there is no certainty
more
or deca will take up either job and even
less certainty that if they do so
they will be able to turn around the
relevant organizations
but the announcements are a good sign
because they suggest
that the conservatives might finally be
showing some fight
in the culture and institutional wars
that conservatives
have traditionally lost it is
a surprise for after all a year into
office
there had been very few indications that
the johnson government would be any more
stalwart in appointing conservatives
than its two predecessors david
cameron's government
managed to see william shawcross
appointed as the chair of the charity
commission
and andrew roberts as a trustee of the
national portrait gallery
theresa may fared less well the attempt
to put toby young
on to a higher education quango ground
british politics to a near standstill
until young withdrew his candidacy
the same government's efforts to put
roger scrutin
into an unpaid role heading an advisory
commission on buildings
led to even greater pain
in recent years some of us had given up
on the idea that the conservatives could
appoint any conservatives into positions
in public
life as such the more and
daker appointments would be a much
needed volley
one that would demonstrate that the
culture wars can no longer be fought and
won
solely by the radical left in the wider
country
there are signs of exasperation over how
one-sided
the cultural battle has been last
weekend
the actor lawrence fox announced the
setting up of a new political party
reclaim to push back against the left
stranglehold over every cultural and
other institution in this country
though it is unlikely to pose much
electoral threat to the conservatives
it could help remind them that assaults
on our history and culture
are not viewed with defeatism or
equanimity
by all of the british public
still the question is not whether daca
and moore can be appointed
but what support they might get and what
other fallacies might be brought in
behind them
how in short to ensure that they are not
one-offs but part of a concerted march
back through the institutions
there is plenty to do for
noble though it is to focus on the bbc
huge amounts of the cultural and
political weather in this country
are set not by the bbc but by the people
whom they report
on and go to in quango after quango
it is the same old story the victims
commissioner
vera baird for instance is a former
labour mp
whose every statement and action fits
the old blair right agenda
yet it was the conservative government
that appointed her to her current
position
in june 2019
but it isn't just about individuals
it is about the cultural attitude
currently embedded
at the roots of the civil service and
every government appointment
when the blair government instituted the
diversity agenda
the conservatives went along with it
cameroon
conservatives saw it not as a right or
left issue
but simply a forwards or backwards issue
a progressive
versus regressive one that
thought rot now runs deeper than almost
any other aspiration in the civil
service
indeed when permanent secretaries write
to their objectives for their roles
the one thing they all have in common
far above the well-being of the country
is the promotion of the diversity agenda
there are signs that the chessboard is
being rearranged
the dismissal of jonathan slater from
his position as permanent secretary
at the department of education was one
good sign
slater was and still is one of the great
twitterers about diversity but it is not
enough just to change the figures on the
board
it is necessary to change the game
slater may have gone but his former
colleagues
still find themselves in the midst of a
pandemic and looming depression
being sent on diversity training and
racial
bias awareness training as though these
gods
sit above all others as the goal and
indeed purpose
of the british state and then
there is the issue of the pilgrims
publicly funded workers who though paid
for by the taxpayer
double up as union officers and
organizers
like so much else the cameron government
ducked
dealing with this scandalous arrangement
but if the johnson administration wants
not just to save money but to
demonstrate a real
change in the wind it would sweep all
these people
off the public payroll
the last labour government rigged almost
every institution in this country
with enormous craft and cunning
even now from the national lottery fund
to the national trust we have
institution after institution in this
country
run by people whose interests are
opposed to those of the general public
and aspiring more than anything else to
the hideous
divisive and now clearly failing
woke agenda daka
and more a good early warning shots
but if the johnson government wants to
do something meaningful
it should not just follow through on
their appointments
it should follow them up with a fuselage
every bit as relentless and long-lasting
as the labour one the repercussions of
which
this country still suffers from that was
douglas murray
and now sam leath we've been reading an
awful lot about
wokeness recently nobody i notice
seems to be much in favor of it in fact
the sharpest pens of the right
seem to stab it more or less nothing
else these days
stab stab stab they go many incisions
are made
and much ink and sawdust is spilled
so being a believer in giving peace a
chance i'd like to sit for a moment on
the bar stool still pleasantly warm from
my colleague rod's momentarily departed
bottom
to offer a word or two in workness's
defense i worry you see
that it might be a bit of an aunt sally
thing is
woke is a term that you now only ever
see used as a sneer
it performs precisely the role that
politically correct
and loony left did in the late 1980s and
early 1990s
reducing a whole range of positions to
the punchline for a rather threadbare
joke
remember when stand-up comics and
tabloid columnists saw one-legged black
lesbian single mothers as a symbol of
the hilarious lunacy of political
correctness gone mad
never mind that such people existed and
i'd say had a pretty tough time of it
and
weren't intrinsically any funnier than
the two-legged variety
we nearly nearest dammit back there one
of my late grandfather's wise sayings
was
nobody ever destroyed a man by sneering
the culture wars are now being conducted
almost entirely through sneering
and as long as they are they will remain
unwinnable now if you want to crush the
left
thank goodness me why wouldn't you woke
won't do it
because it's not an argument so much as
a retreat to the comfort zone
sort of ideological thumb sucking
using woke as a catch-all term of
derogation may elicit sniggers from your
own side
but it betrays a dismaling curiosity
about what it is that you're actually
opposing
and know your enemy remains good advice
you see supposed intellectuals on the
right for instance
denouncing their opponents as marxists
and post-modernists
without pausing to note that these are
contradictory types of thought
just as democratic socialism and
anti-capitalism are quite different
animals
just as within anti-racism or queer
rights campaigning or feminism
there are many different views now you
may see these as the order of precedence
between a laos and a flea
but it's surely worth knowing what
you're disagreeing with
before you write the whole passal off as
a fashionable self-righteous virtue
signaling lefties who would have us all
singing bar bar
green sheep fashionable
self-righteous or virtue signaling all
used in collocation with woke
aren't terms that oppose a position they
instead impute a motive
and rather defensively so at that to do
it as a conjugation
i am principled you are inflexible
he is self-righteous and
why wouldn't you want to be woke in any
case in its original sense as minted in
black activism in the states
to be woke was to be aware it was to
show
just that curiosity about the world that
its use as a sneer
declines to bother with one of the basic
contentions of the non-loony left is
this
a social setup that systematically gives
some people a raw deal
doesn't always make it obvious that it's
doing so we get used to it
this is a contention to which anybody
arguing that it's stupid to cancel
historical figures for holding views
that were widespread in their own age
should surely find it easy to subscribe
to take a well-worn analogy we swim in a
world view
like a fish swims in water the fish
doesn't have a concept of water
because it's all the poor thing has ever
known to be woke
is to go aha this is water
caroline creato perez's recent book
invisible women
gives some good examples men have been
for so long been treated as the default
human specimen
but many people including women don't
even notice the absurdity of this
so the medical advice on the symptoms of
a heart attack for example
describes how men experience it but it
turns out that women's heart attacks
manifest differently crash death dummies
and seat belts are modeled on the male
body shape
office central heating systems are
typically adjusted to male body
temperatures
and so on to be woke is to notice this
stuff and perhaps want to do something
about it rennie eddo lodges
why i'm no longer talking to white
people about race seeks to do something
similar in another arena
it's a thoughtful attempt to explain
what is meant by structural racism
and why it tends to be invisible to its
beneficiaries and you know what
i was put onto it by my 70-something
white south african-born father
he said it changed his view of the world
he took the time to read and think about
an unfamiliar point of view and i guess
he got woke
in a broader sense then you could say
that to be woke is to show curiosity
about other people
to aspire to enlarge your range of
sympathy it is to take an interest in
how the world may look
from another perspective and in that
respect the aspiration to be woke
is in line with the basic project of the
enlightenment to question received ideas
and see if your assumptions are
susceptible to disproof
there are many good reasons to want to
give that a shot which self-respect is
only one
in curiosity we'll come back to bite you
think of poor silly lawrence fox
who thought that casting seeks of
soldiers on the western front in 1917
was evidence of loony-left political
correctness in the filmmakers turned out
there were rather a lot of sikhs
fighting in the first world war
in fact he didn't think that there were
couldn't be bothered to investigate and
looked silly when proved wrong
might have led a subtle mind to wonder
whether his impressions of history were
a bit simplistic it might have made him
think
this stuff could it be water
now there are many on the work left be
it said who are in its proper sense
not woke at all there's nothing woke
about caricaturing everyone on the right
as a fascist a phobe or what have you
the non-idiotic lefty will know the
difference between a berkey and
conservative
and an acolyte vein rand the non-idiotic
lefty
will see that there's more to an honest
reckoning with the past then cancelling
everyone who was alive at the time of
slavery and didn't go on a black lives
matter march right there and then
but you don't engage the non-idiotic
lefty by tilting quixote-like
at the behavior of his most idiotic
fellow traveller that tribal in
curiosity
appears to be everywhere and the
national conversation is much the poorer
for it
so let's all stop sneering and get woke
eh that was sam leath
melissa kite now the pile of fly tipping
was dumped in the night as usual right
against the five bar gate
i arrived to feed the horses and found
seven fridges and a pile of mattresses
blocking the entrance to the field
i raised my eyes to heaven and said
thank you god
the rotting mattresses and busted filthy
fridges lying with their doors open
blocked almost the entire pulling the
feel gate and the style
i believe nicholas van hoogstraden once
powered up a load of old fridges to
block walkers from looking into his
garden from a footpath
well maybe i know how he felt no rambler
no matter how many national trust
stickers he has in his car window
can park up to ramble around my horses
and cause havoc
with seven fridges piled up against the
gate
by the way i see the national trust
lavish
latest tv advert depicts a silent stream
with a caption suggesting
we all need peace and quiet yes but what
peace and quiet have national trust
members allowed me to have for the past
six months
as they run rampant through the surrey
countryside none
as the builder boyfriend and i stood
among the fridges two walkers
marched past tutting their disapproval
one of them took out his phone and
photographed the registration
of our car yeah that's right said the bb
as they walked off all that came out of
a volvo
if the fly tipping backlog is big enough
it will take the council a while to come
and shift this lot
i know mayor giuliani had a lot of
success with his broken windows policy
keeping things so nice in new york
neighborhoods that even yobs didn't want
to drop litter
but i tend to the view that when you are
dealing with the problems of surrey
the best deterrent is to make the place
look a right dump
that way the middle class trespassers
don't want to walk their cockapoos
around your field
because it doesn't look all chocolate
boxy while the fly tip has never tip on
top of fly tipping for reasons i've yet
to fully understand
it seems to be a hard and fast rule
perhaps there is honor among fly tippers
and they don't like to tip on top of
each other's tipping patches
in any case the bb who understands these
things assured me no self-respecting
night tipper
will go near my field entrance now and
hopefully no
day tripper will either we kicked around
the fridges
and found one of them was covered in
fridge magnets the builder bee likes to
do detective work on fly tipping and
he's very good at
it one time he forensically examined a
big dump of rubble outside his field
until he unearthed a receipt leading him
to a well-spoken professional chap
in worcester park he rang him and
interrogated him
expertly to find that he had just had
some building waste removed by a
clearance company
the bb demanded the details and when the
man refused he informed him that if he
didn't tell him he would that very
afternoon
bring all the rubble back to his house
in worcester park and dump it on his
lawn
whereupon the man divulged the clearance
company's full details
and the bb rang them to ask if they
would do a job for him
delighted they asked for the details and
he gave them the address of his field
the man on the other end of the line
began to stutter but the bb held firm
that's right you're going to come back
and clear the rubbish you dumped by my
horses
and when you're done i won't call the
police and give them all the evidence so
they can come and crush your truck
the fly tipper julie turned up bang on
the time arranged
and meticulously cleared up the rubbish
he had flighted
hopeful of another such victory we
kicked around the broken fridges
noticing bailing twine which suggested
they'd been stored in a rural lock-up
somewhere
house clearance after house clearance
until the tow rags had enough fridges to
warrant
a nighttime dumping expedition they
charge 30 to 40 pounds ago for fridges
at local authority tips
and nearly as much for a mattress so
even the professional clearance
companies see no harm in getting the
council to clear them for free by doing
it this way
we scrutinized the fridge with the
magnets which spelt out rude words and
phrases badly
it also bore a sticker for a famous gym
company
i suggested we put a photo on facebook
do you recognize this fridge
but do we really want to do the
council's job for them and find the
culprits
not really we want to take this precious
gift of respite
and enjoy some blessed peace and
security who stratham the style
that was melissa kite and now toby young
from the moment i started criticizing
the government's handling of the
coronavirus crisis
people have been urging me to start an
anti-lockdown party
the idea would be to run candidates in
the local elections in may
particularly in those areas that have
been under almost permanent lock and key
for the past six months
such as leicester they might not win but
they could bleed enough support from the
conservative candidates
to make the government think twice about
its forever lockdown policy
but i've resisted for one thing i don't
have the time
running the free speech union and
posting daily updates to my lockdown
skeptics blog
as well as trying to earn a living as a
journalist means i'm already working 14
hours a day
caroline would divorce me if i took on
anything else
then there's the electoral commission
i've seen the way it has gone after
friends who campaigned for leave in the
eu referendum
above all there's the sheer nastiness of
politics
starting a new party is like sticking a
big target on your back
inviting the most vicious malignant
people in the country to take a shot at
you
that's not much fun particularly if
you've got four kids at school
so i take my hat off to lawrence fox
who's doing exactly what i'm too
cowardly to do
the 42 year old actor is starting a
party called
reclaim that will stand up for liberty
particularly freedom of speech
and is unashamedly patriotic it's been
described as the
ukip of the culture wars but that's not
quite right as lawrence voted for remain
and won't be campaigning for less
immigration he's less of a
gnt in the saloon bar type more an
aperol spritz in the beach bar man
if nigel farage is terry thomas lawrence
is david niven
there's also something appealingly
normal about him
he hasn't been harboring political
ambitions for years waiting for the
right moment to strike
rather he's been propelled into the
front line by the government's
unwillingness to do anything about the
takeover
of the civil service the police the bbc
universities schools
museums and galleries by the woke left
he reminds me of the peter finch
character in network who leans out of
his office
window and screams i'm as mad as hell
and i'm not gonna take this anymore
lawrence is in the process of
registering reclaim with the electoral
commission
and intends to contest some seats next
may many people have pointed out
that britain's first-past-the-post
electoral system means new parties
rarely get anywhere
but that is to ignore the inroads that
proportional representation has made
elections to england's regional chambers
including the london assembly
are based on a form of pr as our
elections to the devolved parliaments
more importantly reclaim doesn't have to
win anything in order to make a
difference
ukip only managed to win a single
parliamentary seat
yet it achieved its main political
objective all lawrence needs to do
is persuade the conservative party that
if it doesn't become more robust or
culture war issues
it will lose votes to him in red wall
seats not enough for reclaim to win
but enough for labour to come up through
the middle
and lawrence's initiative has already
had a backbone stiffening effect on
number 10
with its comms team frantically briefing
out that boris was planning to appoint
charles moore to run the bbc and paul
daker to run offcom at the same time
that the story broke about the new party
with his backbenchers growing restive
boris is particularly vulnerable to the
charge that he hasn't done enough to
protect britain's statues and monuments
from marauding gangs of black lives
matter protesters
or to defend britain's history from
those who portray it as an
unending litany of exploitation and
oppression
if the new party starts creeping up in
the polls boris will have to do
something to shoot
reclaims fox of course
there are other things the conservatives
could do to spike lawrence's guns
i had lunch with him on monday and asked
him whether he was prepared for the
black ops team
central office as no doubt already
dispatched to take him out
fending off the karate on twitter is one
thing but the tory party's character
assassins are likely to be more deadly
he said he was ready to take on all
comers they can punch me in the face as
often as they like
i'll just get right back up again he
said i could almost hear the theme from
the dam busters drifting across the
table
that was toby young thanks for listening
to this podcast and
do join us again next week
you can subscribe to the spectator for
12 weeks for only 12 pounds
for our print and online editions plus
get six months of digital access free to
the telegraph
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash telegraph
forward slash telegraph forward slash
telegraph